you may remember that when I was in
Paris a couple of years ago I mentioned
how thrilled I was when I arrived at the
airport I was expecting to have to pay
to get on the train into downtown Paris
and it was just free and I thought this
is amazing you just show up in Paris and
they have free public transit of course
it wasn't actually free what was going
on is that Paris has had this policy
where when they determined that air
pollution is high at dangerous levels in
order to encourage people to leave their
cars at home and take public transit
they make public transportation free and
yesterday was the second day in a row
that Paris made public transportation
completely free to fight the major spike
in air pollution that's been going on
they also have banned some cars from
driving around and the way they do this
is based on the either odd or even
ending number of the license plate that
you have you're only allowed to drive
into the city on certain days and the
previous day it was I believe the first
day was even-numbered cars are allowed
to drive in and on day two
it was the odd-numbered license plates
that were allowed to drive in I think
that this is absolutely fantastic
however I think that when you're seeing
this happen more and more there's some
bigger picture issue we need to be
addressing here if the air is so bad
that it's dangerous to walk around in
public because of the particles of
pollution that are in it just saying
let's make public transit free today
we're probably thinking a little bit too
small aren't we right because I don't
think that this type of ban will have
any lasting effect and they've already
previously been warned of this when
their air quality index was the worst in
the world briefly in 2015 but I'm kind
of wondering if they shot themselves in
the foot with all of the diesel cars
well in what way what by doing by doing
what with the diesel cars and in terms
of them being counterproductive with
emissions oh well yeah I mean diesel
cars have lower emissions than gas cars
so you're saying that by switching to
diesel cars
in the way much of Europe has that they
were sort of saying this is the way in
which we're going to reduce emissions
but then now they're having pollution
problems anyway after recently having
made such a big initiative to move over
in the direction of diesel yes that is
okay imagine what would happen in
American cities if the mayor were to
come out and say if your license plate
number ends in an odd number you're not
allowed to drive into the capital
tomorrow Americans would go bonkers if a
mayor were to do this
yeah because most people think you have
a right to drive in this country and
also our public transportation systems
for the most part just aren't good
enough to do a program like this in many
cities they're not and many cities
around the world have done this Mexico
City Bogota Beijing Stockholm Sweden has
done it Stockholm is not known for a
particularly bad pollution but they put
in something called a low emission zone
in 1996 which banned cars from
particular areas in the Swedish capital
of Stockholm if they fall below certain
European Union emission standards what
seems to be the case and Pat sort of
alluded to this rachel is that even
though this has been tried in a lot of
cities around the world it only seems to
actually work when there's a good public
transportation system if you just ban
cars in a city that has a less than
ideal public transit system you're
actually just drastically reducing
productivity by making it really
difficult for people to get to work to
me this reinforces the importance not
only of a bigger solution but of the
importance of public transit in all
major cities I completely agree with
that but as I said before I don't really
understand the importance of a short ban
because even if the levels initially
we'll go down they'll spike right back
up of course yes that's that's why it's
just it's it's a great effort it's great
to say it's dangerous to be outdoors
today don't drive and take free public
transit but it is not a long-term
solution and it's sad reading comments
about what Paris did on American news
websites and you have Americans saying
this isn't freedom what is happening in
Paris is because the air is dangerous to
your health
and Americans are complaining about the
lack of freedom because they're not
allowed to drive it just seems like such
a
taking your head in the sand and a
misplaced a priority and there's also so
many Americans who just believe that
humans have no impact on the climate no
impact on the environment so that's why
it couldn't possibly work here it's so
funny how on the one hand you have
people who think we have no impact on
the on the climate yet when you reduce
the number of cars driving into Paris
then the pollution does actually go down
I mean talk about cause and effect
it's amazing that some people don't seem
to understand that that's what's going
on
there's also another issue here and we
talked about this in our interview
yesterday which is the lack of
affordability in cities why are so many
people needing to drive from the suburbs
into the city because they can't afford
to live in the city with the job that
they have in the city and I think that
this is also Rachel a really big
discussion about class and we see this
in Boston we see this in New York City
the fact that we have so many commuters
is partially related to that's the only
place they can afford to live that's
true but I don't really see how that
would feasibly shift
I fed quarters are gonna stay in cities
and the demand to live there to be in a
close proximity to the best paying jobs
isn't really going to change yeah I mean
as we talked about yesterday with Miguel
on the show part of it is owning part of
it is infrastructure spending that
doesn't just go to make cities even more
desirable in the way that drives up
rents even more you've got to do some
strategic infrastructure spending in a
way that will actually make cities more
affordable rather than less yeah it's
also interesting because a lot of people
who were speaking about the the fire in
Oakland were saying that a large reason
not this happened and people were living
there in unsafe conditions is because
they couldn't afford to live elsewhere
yeah I mean I don't doubt that
whatsoever I hadn't heard that analysis
but Oakland and as a San Francisco
suburb even though Oakland in and of
itself is starting to actually get
expensive in some areas is front and
center in this problem of lack of
affordability of liberal American cities
all right we will take a break
facebook.com slash David Pakman show
make sure you give us a like there
Gamefly is sort of like Netflix for
video games they have over 8,000 new and
classic games for xbox one Xbox 360 ps4
ps3 Wii and a bunch of other platforms
and you can play as many games as you
want for one month
we fee and if you find some games you
want to keep you can buy them for a low
used price there's never any due dates
or late fees and our audience can get a
free 30-day trial at Gamefly offer.com
slash TDP s the games are shipped
directly to you with return envelopes
included there's no contracts and you
can rent games through the mobile app
get the free 30-day trial for the David
Pakman show audience and support our
show by going to Gamefly offer.com slash
TDP s